we champion loose associations here on
the gist and since it's basically Easter
and we did see that awesome Megalodon
shark in battlefield 4 the other day I
reckon we should talk about super cool
gaming Easter eggs here's a list of some
of my favorites but do let me know if I
miss out on yours it's a pretty great
thing when a wonderful rumor and a cool
developer meet and such was the case
with Diablo 2 secret cow level around
the time Diablo the first was released
rumors of a secret cow level spread like
wildfire unfortunately that was not the
case initially you but filiz had proved
they were good guy Greg's by delivering
an actual secret cow level as an easter
egg in Diablo 2 and it's not only do you
fight a horde of cranky cows but there's
also a cow king to be defeated for loot
glory and bragging rights if you have
the skills it's pretty amusing I'm sorry
about that
next up I've got a couple of Easter eggs
from a game you might actually be
playing GTA 5 is a treasure trove of
references but some of them do get a
little creepy
first up there's a stack of UFOs that
you can find around the place the first
is submerged up north and the next three
appear once you've reached 100%
completion pushing into the downright
supernatural there's also the ghost of
Jolene crane lee-evans who wants the top
of Mount Gordo at around 11:00 p.m. at
night if you want your GTA 5 play to go
from criminal fun times to horror in 60
seconds
speaking of hora the survival horror
series Silent Hill is pretty well known
for having multiple endings and joke
endings but some are a little more
bizarre than others perhaps the most
obscure is the so called dog ending from
Silent Hill 2 you need to finish the
game three times which then allows you
to find a secret key in a dog house you
eventually use this key to unlock a door
and meet Mira a Shiba inner dog who's
been controlling the events of the
entire game with her canine prowess
when James confronts Mira she seems to
lick his face and then that's that
hilarity ensues though which makes the
drastic change in torn pretty welcome
and my favorite Easter Egg comes from
the middle gift solid series this is a
perfect example of what makes the
madness of Metal Gear so great there's a
boss battle with a character called the
end in Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake Eater
who puts up a real fight he's an elderly
master sniper with the ability to
photosynthesize for some reason and he
has a real knack for camouflaging
himself in the Russian wilderness
if played the regular way the battle
involves crawling very slowly through
grass and painstakingly searching the
dense jungle prakruti is whereabouts
without exposing yourself this battle
can usually take up to an hour on
average but this isn't your only option
you can if you so choose begin the fight
with the end and then turn off the game
and either wait a week or fast-forward
your console system clock either option
will result in the end having died from
old age when you pop back into the game
alternatively you can snipe him when you
see him sitting in a wheelchair much
earlier in the game and avoid the battle
altogether
either way really last week I offered up
my opinions on whether I thought the
Elder Scrolls online would appeal to
Elder Scrolls fans and you guys had a
lot to say about it
death of the ninja pointed out all that
it said throughout this video in Skyrim
Skyrim Skyrim wasn't there other games
before and why do we have to compare an
MMO from ZeniMax online to Skyrim made
by Bethesda Game Studios
Skyrim is certainly used as an example
in this video but it's not the only
comparison that's being drawn it's a
fair point to note that the games are
developed by different Studios but to
stack up single-player
and massively multiplayer RPGs and think
about how fans of one might respond to
the holiday you have to find some points
of reference winter ray added I really
have to disagree on the graphics the
Elder Scrolls online is so much better
looking than Skyrim if you've got the
hardware to support it it definitely
adds to the immersion of the game and to
me Aaron really never looked that great
to begin with you do have a good point
there while I was mostly disappointed in
the animations the world of the Elder
Scrolls online does have a certain
aesthetic skill to refer though a lot of
the vertical opinions can be summed up
in the source of Dan Mullen
it's an MMO first and Elder Scrolls
seconds to be honest I've heard plenty
more great Easter Egg suggestions like
Minecraft in Borderlands and the chicken
in Gears of War but do let me know what
your all-time favorites are in that
comment section below and I'll see you
next week